ana welcome to Campeche it's great to be
here look we got juice boxes we got
candy coloring books you need to relax
were you at Camp 4 as a kid I my dad
would make me go to camp and I hated it
did not like at all there's so many bugs
he was a military man so he thought we
had to have survival skills did you look
actually learn any no jokes on him I'm
on the internet now hahahaha what number
VidCon is this for you this is my third
year at VidCon and every year has gotten
progressively busier and crazier right
it's been fun you got work to do you got
a lot to promote mm-hmm let's not miss
2059 no way how did that project find
Jill and now it's out in the world well
I was a part of new form digital's
incubator program so I was one of the
first pilots that they made and they
went ahead and took that pilot and took
it to various digital platforms we ended
up selling it to go 9d thanks go 90
verizon yeah and so we got now it's
available on go 90 the app is free the
series is completely free to watch it's
not even an ad-supported model and I
will thank you for stopping by camp et
thanks pray we are excited to watch
everything as it comes out this year hey
thank so much exciting stuff yeah miss
2014 ongoing 90s got lots of women watch
it